if you've been hearing that extreme cold
spells like the one that we're having in
the United States now disprove global
warming don't believe it
the fact is that no single weather
episode can either prove or disprove
global climate change climate is the
pattern of weather that we observe
geographically and over the seasons and
it's described in terms of averages
variations and probabilities but a
growing body of evidence suggests that
the kind of extreme cold being
experienced by much of the United States
as we speak is a pattern that we can
expect to see with increasing frequency
as global warming continues and the
reason is this in the warming world that
we're experiencing the far north the
Arctic is warming roughly twice as
rapidly as the mid latitudes such as the
United States that means that the
temperature difference between the
Arctic and the mid latitudes is
shrinking and that temperature
difference is what drives what is called
the circumpolar vortex which is the
great counter clockwise swirling mass of
cold air that hovers over the Arctic as
the temperature difference between the
Arctic and the mid latitudes declines
the polar vortex weakens and it becomes
wavier the waviness means that there can
be increased larger excursions of cold
air southward that is into the mid
latitudes and in the other phase of the
wave increased excursions of relatively
warmer mid-latitude air into the far
north computer models tell us that there
are many different factors influencing
these patterns and as in all science
there will be continuing debate about
exactly what is happening but I believe
the odds are that we can expect as a
result of global warming to see more of
this pattern of extreme cold in the
mid-latitudes and some extreme warm in
the far north
you